seven years after the water crisis in
flint another michigan community is
struggling with high levels of lead in
its water residents of the predominantly
black and low-income city of benton
harbor are being urged by the state to
use only bottled water for cooking and
drinking take a look at this in benton
harbor there are up to 889
parts per billion of lead and water
based on samples taken over a six month
period earlier this year the epa says
actions should be taken at just a
fraction of that when there are 15 parts
per billion
omar villafranca is in benton harbor for
us omar good morning
good morning water safety is not a new
issue here in benton harbor they've had
problems with lead in the water for the
last three years the city's main water
source is lake michigan then passes
through nearly 6 000 water lines and the
city says more than half are made of
lead
what
water do you use to cook
the bottled water to brush your teeth
bottle water
bathe
bottled water
for many people bottled water is
becoming a way of life in the small city
of benton harbor michigan population 9
700.
earlier this month the state started
giving out more free cases of bottled
water due to ongoing concerns about lead
levels in the city's water supply
these are water filters but reverend
edward pinckney is frustrated before you
can correct the problem you have to
acknowledge there's a problem work
together he says michigan governor
gretchen whitmer has not gone far enough
to warn people about the risk
do you think that we're not even at the
point where
leaders are acknowledging the problem oh
absolutely absolutely the governor said
precautionary reasons she should be
saying that the water is unsafe to drink
benton harbor's water problems stem from
corrosion of the city's lead service
lines the state says corrosion control
treatment has made modest improvements
but levels are still high in some
sampled homes
according to the cdc lead exposure is
especially dangerous for children in
part it can damage the brain and nervous
system
this is the same thing that you might
find in benton harbor or any other
community with lead service lines water
safety consultant elon baitanzo says
it's difficult for the average person to
know if there's lead in their water you
cannot see smell or taste lead in
drinking water if you if there's color
in the water that's usually from iron or
other contaminants there can be very
high levels of lead in a glass of water
and there's no change in appearance
benton harbor mayor marcus mohammed says
it will cost at least 30 million dollars
to replace the pipes 28 million dollars
of state and federal money has been
allocated to fix the problem but it's
been slow to arrive
this summer benton harbor received 5.6
million dollars which was approved
during the obama administration muhammad
expects all the city's lead lines to be
replaced within the next two years is
that timetable satisfactory for you
because you've known about this and the
city has known about this for a few
years now right if i had a magic wand
i would solve it right now
but in government things don't work that
way the reality of the matter is it
takes time it takes money it takes
resources has any work started on fixing
any pipes even if it's not complete
work has started on fixing pipes but
it's a slow motion thing when people say
this takes time
what do you tell them
we don't have
time further complicating things a water
expert told us when fewer people use the
water the problem gets worse because the
water just ends up sitting in the pipes
for longer the city's next round of
compliance testing will be completed in
december
omar thank you seems like yesterday we
were sending gallons of water to flint
for the people of benton harbor we hope
that this gets fixed i mean these things
don't seem to happen in white affluent
neighborhoods it's because the money is
there to make the replacements it
happened decades ago or years ago uh it
needs to happen now in every community
no doubt about it the money's there and
the people
you're right it doesn't happen in places
like greenwich connecticut beverly hills
california doesn't that gentleman was
right when he said we don't have time
lives are at stake here yeah and brains
brains are insane things that need to be
repaired are oftentimes overlooked in
places that don't have the money